c'est quoi ces besoins qui fait que les
gens vous fait peur mais je laime même
qui nous ferait pas par an plan combat
par exemple est-ce qui vous défonce et
s'entoure jocko de cette danse un ami à
notre niveau nous tuer avec une fiche
donc forcément elle sait qu on se battra
pas tous les c avec une tasse je peux tu
vois là je peux blessé une centaine de
personnes combien il faut voilà combien
de temps il faut pour maintenir un bon
niveau en partant du niveau de cyril par
quelqu'un sportive collègues ne connaît
ni au stage mais il faut que tu fais du
sport
les frères c'est comme ça c'est ma vie
et du pcot de trois ans
[Rires]
vous voulez vous même vous avez eu une
remise en forme pour faire ça maintenant
je serai le toit c'était pas mal c'était
pas mal je peux être jeu prévenu je
pourrais être mieux ouais non tu peux
passer un peu non vous avez vu la
perfection mais c'est à dire mais jean
claude tu t'es pas entraînant plus il
entraîne tout le temps en fait ouais
ouais mais à des films ou de saintes est
vraiment dans la bonne de bontin de le
faire mais c'est passé bon là on a fait
un truc super tu as fait un truc de ouf
non vraiment c'est très réussi bravo à
des licences et des on a généralisé
envers mais je veux dire que parfois on
se sent un peu mieux que dans l'autre
cette mon ami omar d'action matam iata a
envoyé la wigig dans le film est
évidemment de l'action de la comédie et
pia vos répliques absolument culte à
plein de moments mais vous les improvisé
où on voulait écrire comment ça sort
parce que on s'y attend tellement pas
que 500 ordinaire la sorte aurier yahia
une réplique de balavoine dans le film
mais comme tu es ça tue des trucs de la
tuer et de toi c'est avec la chaire
battue et ça tue stévia et puis tu te
déguise beaucoup dans le film mary
beaucoup de maires vaches les rues et
tout terrain qui fera à wemmel le
directeur enfin acquise mais ça ça
chatouille les gens qui savent supporter
les perruques
tout ce qui restait sur toi tu vois
c'est rien il as un postiche s'enlève le
sens tu voulais dire un truc non moi je
suis fan je suis fan et il a parlé du
budget vous avez dit qu'il avait mis le
paquet sur super nes que ça fait partie
des films où il ya vraiment eu vous avez
senti qu'il y avait vraiment un gros
gros budget ya un grand respect vous
avez parlé de rémy julienne je pense que
c'est l'un de ces derniers ce dernier
film est est ce que vous avez senti
qu'ils avaient vraiment vraiment mis le
paquet à l'abri sur ce film là haut est
directement c'est un netflix
original ils ont ils ont aimé l'idée ils
ont vraiment 1055 jours de tournage
seconde unité voiture
la correction il ya des moyens là il est
un très bon casting connus mais aussi
des acteurs d'une génération différente
donc il y avait de tout j'ai vu qu'elle
espérait beaucoup de deux jeunes qui
jouent avec toi tu fais ça tu comment tu
leur as donné des conseils et tout est
aussi passé beaucoup c'est ça alors j'ai
fait des erreurs au début j'étais un peu
jeune et avec la langue française et
avec l équipe et il ya de vie à tous le
réalisateur etc si l'on est ce qui est
bien quand tu fais un film on est tous
ensemble pendant 2 3 mois et c'est comme
une famille et après quand ça se quitte
c'est très dur ces jeunes et tout ça
fait un coutelas tu as l'air heureux
pardon je trouve le retrait c'est vrai
très très très vraiment je trouve
il attend la faute était bien je trouve
encore mieux que la dernière fois qui
quoi comment ça se fait non non non
quand tu te comprend peut-être que tu
sais tu arrive à un certain âge je te
comprend des choses de faire un vrai
lâche tout son être tranquille capitaine
houat et la mer morte frère tetro kif
un bus et un certain âge j'ai trouvé une
bande de copains qui sont très très
sérieux et thank you tube et je suis je
suis bien entouré avec des gens bien au
contraire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]